[Musique]
nathalie griesbeck bonjour nathalie
griesbeck bonjour bonjour je suis
députée européenne de l'est de la france
qui comprend la bourgogne la franche
comté la champagne ardenne l'alsace et
la lorraine
en tout 18 départements mais surtout
huit millions et demi d'habitants
j'appartiens à un groupe parlementaire
de l'alliance des démocrates et libéraux
en europe notre adn j'ai envie de dire
c'est d'essayer dans tous les dossiers
de trouver des solutions qui soient
proprement européenne j'ai le sentiment
que les préoccupations essentielles de
nos concitoyens sont liées à l'emploi
donc à l'activité économique et à la
sécurité sur le continent ces éléments
peuvent être résolus par des solutions
européennes
madame kris meeke est une collègue qui
j'apprécie beaucoup il y a une
compréhension fondamentale entre nos
deux sur l'idée de l'europe que des
nations et des états de travail au delà
des frontières ensemble
nathalie griesbeck et quelqu'un de
formidable c'est une députée européenne
extrêmement engagée elle a des
convictions très fortes qu'elles
défendent la question des libertés
publiques la question des droits
fondamentaux la question de la
protection des mineurs 2000 enfants qui
sont exposés au froid à la fatigue aux
peurs aux violences au harcèlement au
travail forcé à la prostitution au
désespoir à la disparition de multiples
enfants ont disparu ou aussi à la mort
puisque certains de ces jeunes iglesias
étouffé
dans le cadre de la commission des
libertés de la justice et des affaires
intérieures jai eu la chance de
travailler de la directive sur la
présomption d'innocence pour aboutir la
très beau texte court bref et qui va
être la norme pour les 27 états membres
de l'union européenne
cette directive européenne propose
d'interdire toute déclaration publique
aux décisions officielles émanant
d'autorités publiques qui présenterait
ou même insinuerait qu'une personne
suspecte est coupable avant jugement
j'ai aussi travaillé sur le dossier des
garde-côtes gardes frontières aux
frontières externes de l'union
européenne je suis aussi les investis
dans les dossiers qui concernent la
justice proprement dite le système
d'euros juste mais aussi tous les
dossiers qui ont trait aux données
personnelles des citoyens européens et
en particulier sur la thématique de la
protection des enfants je travaille sur
le texte de la lutte contre la pédo
pornographie en ligne et plus
généralement aussi dans l'interview
droits des enfants
c'est un intergroupe qu'on a créé avec
quelques députés et nous avons fait
railler nous nous sommes battus et j'ai
obtenu qu'il soit créé au début de cette
mandature et ce qui nous permet de
réussir à nous organiser
et en mettant la cause des enfants dans
presque tous les taxes s'agisse des
textes dans l'industrie sur le travail
des enfants sur l'habitat sur l'emploi
sur les affaires sociales sur la culture
sur la santé évidemment sur les droits
fondamentaux des enfants
c'était difficile mais on l'a obtenu
d'ailleurs on appelle notre équipe là
l'équipe des champions susan rice
les démocraties que nous sommes traités
des enfants vulnérables comme nous le
faisons c'est pas possible j'ai sauvé 6
les friendly and lynch négociée tout
état de cause des fréquentes crises
comme des frères pour l'éthique à
l'europe elle est très fort impliqué sur
ce qui touche directement les gens joie
tout à l'heure mais nous étions entrain
discuter du dossier qui concerne alstom
caterpillar dont est une chose se fait
concrète par rapport à la réalité
quotidienne des citoyens dans l'union
européenne
[Musique]
si c'est une épicerie solidaire j'en
entends ma responsabilité d'élus qu'en
phase étroite avec le terrain ici c'est
un exemple magnifique apporter des
réponses adaptées à des situations qui
sont différentes sur les 18 départements
l'eurodéputée modem nathalie griesbeck
on visite aujourd'hui à charleville
mézières une visite sous le signe de
l'europe donc l'europe et son action
dans les ardennes les fonds européens
s'élèvent à plus de 10 millions d'euros
pour la formation et l'insertion dans le
département ne doit pas être traité
comme si on était des dossiers on doit
être traité à la mesure de ce qu'on
demande ça aussi le propre des
démocraties
ce qui est plus compliqué pour moi c'est
de réussir à répondre sur un territoire
qui est immensément va cela tout à
l'heure j'avais un dossier pour
quelqu'un qui est à lipsheim en alsace
monsieur il vient de vendeuvre du 54 en
fin de journée je serai à plus de
planches olap ça c'est la vie d'un élu a
fait des moments passionnants par
exemple ce qu'il explique
on a un dialogue ça me permet de
rires aussi intellectuellement et
spirituellement ce que je fais comme
législateur
nathalie elle à cette passion qu'elle
communique cette passion de l'europe
qu'elle a une proximité avec les gens
elle comprend les choses une femme
politique de terrain et je crois que ça
c'est irremplaçable
les gens trouvent leur rampe illisible
mais en même temps on n'a jamais eu
autant le sentiment que seules des
réponses européennes peuvent résoudre
des difficultés qui sont les nôtres donc
ce paradoxe il faut l'intégrer il faut
le dépasser en essayant de trouver
évidemment avec d'autres élus les voir
une forme d'espoir pour les européens et
pour l'avenir de nos enfants
[Musique]